[Música]
quem é que estava ter uma vida melhor do
que ela tem o que venho aqui fora e
tentar trazer uma perspectiva entre a
qualidade das nossas escolhas e aqui o
que é a nossa vinda aqui nós fazemos ao
longo de um dia pensei num dia normal
nossa vida o que quer o que quer que
seja que se quer dizer quanto é que o
fazem a escolha vossa daquilo que
fazemos 0 a 100 por cento
é uma escolha nossa eu vou fingir que
você está a mesma nota mental daquilo
que foi a vossa resposta e vou conversar
um pouco conosco sobre esta mesma
pergunta difícil
eu prometo dar uma resposta que sendo
linha
atrevo a dizer no final desta conversa
pode ser a todos nós e resposta que eu
dou é que a nossa escolha é a quantidade
de coisas que fazemos no dia a dia é
100%
eu trabalho em desenvolvimento
organizacional e estão a faltar apenas
dizer ajudar empresas e organizações a
melhorar em sua performance e muitas
vezes já fiz essa pergunta desde meados
da década de 90 é milhares de pessoas
entre as organizações
tipicamente a resposta nunca é 100 por
cento
salvo raras exceções à parte das pessoas
respondeu qualquer coisa entre os 60 e
os 40 depois a um grupo nó respondendo
aos 31 20 outro igualmente norte entre
cursos de 70 e 80
- ainda há vagas para as contas em três
vezes
alguns outros proventos e rafael muito
poucos são aqueles que escondem 100%
porque está assim porque a maioria nós
não vê não acredita que são 100% da
nossa escolha em tudo o que nós fazemos
ao longo do dia
nós perguntamos às pessoas
exemplos coisas que fazem não escolhem
tipicamente o que nos dizem pode ser
agrupados em quatro tipos de argumentos
o primeiro eo mais fácil lidar
é quando as pessoas dizem eu não escolho
nascer era uma discussão eventualmente
importante pelo saque
a questão é que não foi essa pergunta as
pessoas respondem é uma questão que
mexer biológico podemos conquistar aqui
sobre os livros da loja cheia todos os
dias um pouco mas não é essa a pergunta
que foi feita não é essa a resposta está
em questão que tanto nos ter sendo uma
escolha nossa era uma discussão que
vamos ter não conta
a segunda é idêntica é quando as pessoas
dizem coisas como eu não escutei um
acidente
eu não escolhi ficar lenta também era
discutível encostavam qualquer modo a
pergunta não é essa a pergunta não é
quanto aquilo que vos acontece escolhem
então tudo o que são coisas que nos
acontecem está fora da pergunta que foi
colocada
sobram duas e as duas das quatro
iniciais a terceira
são coisas com as respostas do gênero eu
não escolhi respirar
eu não escolho dormir e comer beber e
consequentemente ir à casa de banho
quando esta questão é levantada a minha
conta pergunta é esta
escolhe nascer num elas estão com isso
scott estar vivo
naturalmente que as pessoas olhem para
mim e pensam que são fruto da retórica
mas não é
nós lutamos por estar vivos nós queremos
continuar vivo
temos pessoas de ver se é uma escolha
nossa estar vivos
então há um pacote de escolhas associava
a escolha está vivo tais como dormir e
respirar e comer de ir à casa de banho
são as escolhas físicos são as escolhas
fisl11 pessoas nas cidades de seu agente
das quatro iniciais dos quatro grupos de
argumentos que as pessoas costumam dar
para justificar não escolhem 100% o que
fazer só um quarto que talvez mais
importante falar nos que são pessoas não
como as obrigações execução eu não
escolho levantaram as tais o acerto para
trabalhar ou pra estudar eu não vou
pagar contas nomeadamente os impostos na
escola e pegaram um poste
eu não escolhi cozinhar quando chipre 3
em uma casa cansado alcançada pela
família
eu não escolhi a pegar trânsito tudo
isto são questões válidas e eu
compreendo que as pessoas digam isto
quando estas questões são levantadas
o que eu pergunto e
então o que aconteceria se não fizesse
aquilo que soube com escolhe a pessoa
começa a explicar e partir deste domingo
e precisou ir até o fim
é porque sou cônsul falar qual é a
alternativa não acordaram para haver uma
escolha qual é o menino alternativas
temos que ter qual é um mínimo de
civilidade duas acho que conseguimos
todos concordar com isto é a partir do
momento em que a pessoa fala do início
da segunda ela está a dizer fez uma
escolha mas mais do que falar da
alternativa a pessoa tá
conseqüência e é uma conseqüência que
conseguimos perceber melhor o porquê das
pessoas que responderem a corresponder
porque entra em cena um momento
fundamental nesta noção dos perigos ou
não e entra em cena é que o que nós
sentimos em relação ao presente
por outras palavras se nós formos
simplista sexta a conversa tem que ser
macho que possível as linhas não estão
juntas portão percebe um aumento que a
zona neutra há coisas que eu faço e nem
penso que vou fazer mas essencialmente a
dois tipos de sentimentos lançou faça as
coisas que eu gosto das coisas que eu
não gosto
há coisas que eu gosto outras que gosta
ainda mais outras que gosto muito e
outras que ora em relação ao que eu
gosto
há coisas que eu não gosto das coisas
que gosto de coisas boas têm menos que
há coisas que o texto se eu puder vou
evitar a todo custo
vamos fazer primeiro um exemplo é fácil
falar um pouco de mim e eu gosto de
praia gosta do euro e de vez em quando
gosta de demonstrar dinheiro o meu tempo
com os amigos dizem possa ir à praia
lá ler um livro eventualmente beber uma
cervejinha tranquilo agora aqui nos dias
em que todos eventualmente já obtivemos
aos tempos em que não nos apetece
trabalhar
não nos apetece ir à escola o que é que
faz com que nós vamos trabalhar nesse
mesmo nós temos a consciência de que
embora possamos não gostar
há uma conseqüência ainda maior se nós
não fizermos aquilo que não gostando e
como tal nós que escolhemos ir trabalhar
para evitar uma coisa que é ainda pior
o que temos que fazer para evitá lá que
não ter casa não poder pagar na nossa
casa não podia pagar a comida negócio e
daquilo que eventualmente possam nós
depender da idade possam ter no fundo
são escolhas que nós fazemos embora
sejam coisas que nós não gostamos de
fazer
e aqui por vezes que entra a dificuldade
das pessoas perceberem o quanto escolhem
mesmo sendo coisas que não gostam de se
desligar os isto é um evento tem a ver
com fundamental na vida das pessoas que
é o momento da ativação da palavra
motivação recorre novamente as tenha
apercebido disso é a junção da palavra
motivo para a ação
por outras palavras é a razão pela qual
fazemos o que quer que seja que fazem e
quais são as motivações que o ser humano
tem
quais suas motivações que a reação era
potter e virtualmente impossível
virtualmente impossível responder porque
são tantas que no limite pode dizer que
há sempre mais uma que não tinha pensado
com a secção tendencialmente infinitas
contudo para expandir o nosso
eventualmente pode conseguir se arrumar
em duas caixas apenas o que eu vou dizer
o que outros autores
já falaram muitas vezes ocupe wall e
sentimento das motivações que são as
coisas que nós gostamos e as coisas que
nós fazemos para evitar outras pior do
que o que temos que fazer para evitá las
por outras palavras nós estamos a falar
de aquilo que consideramos ser e neste
caso a busca do brasileiro o jogador o
que deseja que nós possamos fazer um
sopro busca trazer o jogador busca fazer
com que o custo agosto o jogador é que
fazemos para evitar uma conseqüência
temos na cabeça e ainda pior se não
fizemos eu tenho que fazer para evitá lo
agora pense nisto quanto a nossa vida em
termos genéricos
nós passamos em busca de prazer e quanto
é que passamos em fuga
como é conhecido tem para nós passar os
grandes quantidades do dia em fugas dor
e grande quantidade de dias é fundador
se isso acontecer se nós tivermos a
fazer um conjunto de coisas que não
gostamos de fazer é natural como cinza
desenvolver uma coisa que seja algo na
nossa cabeça para evitar o sofrimento
que estamos conscientes que estamos a
escolher coisas que não gostamos de uma
força mental que é necessário termos
constituinte está nos dias meses anos
grande parte do nosso tempo fazer um
conjunto de coisas que sabemos que somos
nós queremos mas constante e dizer eu
vou fazer isso texto eu escolhi é
difícil muito difícil é normal
muitas vezes a parte das vezes enquanto
implementa é começarmos a contar uma das
piores mentiras que vamos encontrar nos
próprios é começarmos a dizer
e pior ainda acreditar eu não escolho
isto porque quando nós começamos a dizer
que nós criamos uma série de coisas na
nossa vida que naturalmente discutirmos
nós começamos a desenvolver ao chama e é
um conceito psicologia eu vou apresentar
eu sou da economia estão recorrendo se
ocorrer um conceito da psicologia
estamos a falar de uma coisa que é o que
os psicólogos chamam o bloco de controlo
e esta palavra blocos controlo não é
mais nem menos do que é que o que nós
consideramos ser o centro de comando da
nossa vida
o oxi entrou é que o que nós curtindo
então inconscientemente acreditamos que
está ao comando da nossa vida ea mais
uma vez que manteve conversas entre os
dois tipos de crença
em outras palavras dois tipos blocos com
tronco nós podemos ter interno ou
externo 11 total interno essencialmente
diz que a pessoa acredita que grande
parte do que acontece na vida é
influenciada por si ao longo dos anos
com as suas decisões com suas lutas com
as suas batalhas porque o que ela
decidiu fazer
entre as soluções e que aceita uma forma
genérica sem que o centro possa cuidar
porque se vê como protagonista da sua
vida
ox controle externo é o concorrente de
que uma pessoa que vai já é muito fácil
não escolhe começa a acreditar nos
código e começa a de responsabilização
mais do que centrar as soluções centra
se em desculpas e sentar sem culpados e
quando nós assumimos uma vida em que o
nosso ocs controlo passa a ser
eminentemente externo
nós passamos uma pessoa ser uma pessoa
que basicamente tem um outro parecido
com o kaixin logo existo conhece alguém
assim
meus amigos é uma questão de urgência a
um destes vinte e tal anos
muitas das organizações com as quais
trabalhamos algumas das pessoas com quem
trabalhamos fizemos um atestado que
agora o sport também ea questão é esta
quais são as comunidades quais são as
características vocês mais admiram numa
pessoa
pensei nisso nós colocarmos como os de
esta pergunta
milhares de pessoas centenas de
organizações e por incrível que possa
parecer as respostas não andam muito
longe de 30 ou 40 respostas convidados
que técnicas que as pessoas identificam
um grupo que de críticas normalmente
ouvidas na resposta a esta pergunta mas
antes disso vou falar os de duas
dimensões fundamentais na nossa vida nós
temos essencialmente a dança entre o
esforço e os resultados e na dança entre
as forças resultados
nós tendemos a encontrar um ponto de
equilíbrio onde estamos todos os dias e
esse ponto de equilíbrio e dando o nome
de vata
e quando falamos novato pessoas pensam
que ganhei um conceito altamente
sofisticada academicamente estava não
podia estar mais longe da rodada
o fato quer apenas dizer uma coisa todos
nós já o 20 vão a pena
nós fazemos o que entendemos que foi uma
pena não fazemos mais porque não vale a
pena nem menos porque vale a pena fazer
com que a imagem
então o dito vata que há qualquer coisa
que parece não ligar o nosso esforço e
os nossos resultados em frente em
diferentes pessoas porque aí nós temos
então um pouco atrás perguntar às
pessoas quais são os convidados com
ações que o texto que mais admiro é a
ordem é essa resposta
pegando convosco grande parte do que
elas respondem a alguns exemplos onde se
dá da igualdade humildade generosidade
coragem autenticidade organização
ambição ser altruísta ser um ouvinte
entre mais 20 ou 30 80 a 90 por cento
das vezes são estas 21 30
agora olhando para elas pense nisto há
várias coisas que os compõem
vamos olhar duas delas o conhecimento ea
vontade o saber eo crédito
se você perguntar se por exemplo o al
wahda é mais uma questão de saber o que
é ser um real pode crer que serão e ao
alguém que já protagonizou os do álbum
amigo ou ultrapassar uma crise
matrimonial do amor em que ronaldo fosse
um tema isso aconteceu porque quem foi
desleal não sabia o que queria disse
alda não foi sucinto muito forte não
crer para não serdes cunhal vejo uma
eventualmente mais curiosa organização
claramente é uma questão de saber não é
é o que tendemos a pensar de imediato
então nós pegamos nosso filho a nossa
filha já tem data para ser arrumar o
quarto e ensinamos nem como é que o
quarto arma quando foi ao fado não
disponha roupa onde expõe os brinquedos
onde estão os livros e um já sabe ela já
sabe
a partir daí alguma vez o quarto ataque
formado não tem a ver com quantos
eventos te ver quando queremos qual não
queremos formar e portanto sem crescer
abusivo
o ipca mente a resposta que as pessoas
nos dão em relação à qual das duas é
mais esse moleque douramento uma questão
de vontade o saber é fundamental
ninguém está aqui fazer um atestado de
incompetência desfavor ao ceder o saber
é fundamental
posso crer que assim é terminado e se
nós olharmos então visitando o nosso
papa
o que é que nós temos nós temos que se
perguntar onde é que começa o eu cresço
ir com o novato nos for só nos
resultados
as pessoas costumam dizer vai primeiro
tem que conversar é verdade mas antes
tem que saber porque é que eu estou a
gostar
o que eu quero quero crer o que está na
base da que o mais admiramos nas
características que mais admiramos nas
pessoas que mais admiram e uma vez que
nós tínhamos definido nós crer recusado
a pagar o preço do esforço nós temos
então como conseqüência a relação causa
efeito entre o pensámos que seria o que
temos que fazer para obter um creme
obter estiver certa nosso pinto o nosso
papa
eu vim aqui falar da relação que
acredito que exista entre o poder das
escolhas que a comunidade de vida que
logo quando temos consciência das
escolhas que fazemos é o meu entender é
fundamental e determinante para a
capacidade que temos de aumentar de
fazer subir o nosso a pena e assim
melhoraram significativamente
aquela que a nossa qualidade de vida
esta é uma das grandes forças do poder
das escolhas de ensino esteja envolvido
obrigado
[Aplausos]